we begin today in california where a
series of devastating wildfires in the
west are turning towns
well into ruins in california alone more
than 2 million acres have burned so far
this year
and that is an all-time record utility
blackouts forced by the fires have left
172 thousand homes and businesses
without power at this hour fires are
burning in more than
a dozen western states one of them
destroyed around 80 percent of homes in
a town in eastern washington
and smoke grounded an overnight
helicopter mission
to evacuate dozens of hikers trapped in
the mountains near fresno
jonathan vigliotti is in alder springs
in northern california
jonathan the scenes around some of these
fires are really frightening
good morning to you and these are the
kinds of unbelievable conditions that
rescuers are facing this morning
and why they simply can't get to those
campers that are trapped deep inside
this forest
this wildfire is creating its own
weather system it is simply growing out
of control
and there are not enough firefighters to
hold it back
military pilots attempted several remote
rescue operations monday to try and
evacuate trapped hikers and
campers near fresno california but heavy
smoke from the devastating creek fire
stopped them
at their every turn they weren't able to
land
several times several attempts
throughout the day authorities expanded
evacuation orders
in communities near fresno monday as the
creek fire continued to burn
out of control this thick plume of smoke
was seen from an airplane
the blaze decimated the town of big
creek including toby waite's home
devastation i don't know how else to put
it
it was totally devastating this
is what the community looked like before
the fire
and this is after ground zero where the
creek fire
got its name and where today several
neighborhoods have been reduced to
rubble
and ash the elementary school was one of
the few buildings undamaged
weight is the principal and
superintendent the school is the focal
point of a community
it's the community center it's where we
gather and
to have that still standing that that is
our beacon of hope is that school is
still there
it's still unclear what started the fire
another blaze about 80 miles east of l.a
forced thousands to evacuate there
authorities say a couple
using a smoke generating pyrotechnic
device for a gender reveal
ignited that fire obviously it's
probably going to be a traumatic
experience for them this is not what
what they wanted to remember their child
so
but that doesn't make the accident less
severe
thousands of people are under a
mandatory evacuation those orders are
expected to expand today
as this fire continues to expand more
than 130
000 acres and growing this morning back
to you
be careful jonathan thank you